questions made by the justice secretary
your deputy this morning that there has
been criminality you do accept
criminality
26 penalty notices of the initiative for
goodness sake there can't be any
contradiction entirely
so
i i've been i hope uh very frank with
the house about uh where i think we've
we've
gone wrong
and uh the things that i i regret that i
i apologize for um but in
there is an ongoing
investigation and um
i i understand i understand that i
understand the point you're making
people i'm going to
uh
you know camp pretty firmly on uh on my
position not said anything yeah which is
a taller
question no i understand that and uh
like i understand why you have to ask it
and it's quite right that you do but
i've i'd be very clear i won't
um
give running commentary on an
ongoing investigation can we maybe go
over some of the things that you have
said to us which we do understand which
is a matter of record and you can maybe
help clarify the customer i think very
difficult to understand because first
you said there was no rule breaking that
was right yeah then you claimed you
weren't aware of any of these parties
then you said it was a work meeting then
you said you were outraged by them then
you said you were aware of these events
but they went against the rules and
finally you admitted you were at these
events but you were so ignorant of the
rules you didn't realize you were
breaking them you do understand why the
public has such difficulty with all this
of course pete but uh and you know i i
don't
want to
uh and i understand why why you're
asking the questions and but i just want
to repeat that there will come a point
uh when i will be able uh to
talk about the
investigation and the conclusions of the
of the investigation that is when the
investigation has concluded and i have
no doubt at all that i will be back
before this
committee uh back before
the house of commons uh to talk about it
but at the moment it's it's still going
on and and if it has been found that you
did break the ministerial code which
looking at all the things you said and
all the things that are transparent it's
almost crystal clear that you did that
will mean a resignation issue for you i
i
really great respect pete i think you're
just going to have to uh hold your
uh your horses and wait until and wait
until the conclusion of the
investigation uh when there will be a a
lot more clarity and i will i will be
i'll be back before this
this committee and and i've no doubt
back before the the body of the house
commons and i'd be only too happy to
to
at least today
frustrated and disappointed the public
will be with these responses from you
today they expect some sort of answers i
mean just talk about your leadership in
number 10 i mean i was in rock and roll
for 15 years i mean i could never even
start to compete and keep up with
activities number 10 under lockdown and
the partying culture that you created
was responsible you see that is
i you know i i hear you pete uh but if i
may say so that
you know that is a that is a very good
illustration your question is very good
illustration of why it is important that
we should wait to the uh conclusion of
the of the investigation i think you
famously sacked talking on the rock and
roll theme that i will survive
are you still going to survive it's not
looking good i i i i
just you know respect me say uh
we could never be having
always always to uh only too happy to to
to to
have a
uh you know uh drink with my friends
from the school at the smp
but look uh this is not um something i
can say uh much more about right you
thought you'd got away with it didn't
you you really thought that this was
going to be put aside and nobody would
be interested
you're getting a bit shocked in the
course of the past 24 hours and the
optics lasting of parading your mps in
front of the covent bereaved to go and
party the day that you received fixed
penalty notices was surely
dreadful optics
pete there will be a time for me to
talk to you
at length i mean that's your view uh
you're entitled to your characterization
uh of uh of events that that you can
have no
i wish to
to engage with you in in dispute about
how you how you how you how you choose
to to see things that's not the way i
see things uh but
where where i think you and i are
certainly in agreement
is that it would be right for me to come
back before this committee
and when the investigation is concluded
and to set out what i think and to and
to be properly uh interrogated about uh
about the the findings of the
of the investigators but that that has
not happened yet
uh the thing isn't over uh and um
[Music]
any such discussion is in my view uh
premature right from the move
[Music]
i've done my best too but that there is
literally not a lot more i can say right
okay catherine mckinnon thank you chair
um i've listened very carefully to this
exchange i am in relation to the downing
street lockdown parties
lack of trust
in government is raised regularly in
parliamentary petitions
so prime minister how would you respond
to 130 000 plus petitioners
who are calling for lying in the commons
to be made a criminal offense
i i think that it's very important that
uh you should be
clear with the house of commons and
uh i've i've tried to
be as clear as i can about my
understanding of events uh i've been
back repeatedly to uh before the commons
to uh to explain to uh to apologize for
the things that i think we've uh we've
got wrong
and i've no doubt that i will be i'll be
back again um
but you know there's there's not a lot
more i can say than at the present time
i mean i
very much the words that you use i've
tried to be as clear as i can and i
think that's the big concern people have
is that you're not able to be
clear or straight on these issues if you
can't even answer the question as to
whether any laws were broken in
whitehall during lockdown
when 20 fixed penalty notices were
issued yesterday can you at least give a
clear answer on that
well uh
you you say twenty fixed penalty notices
were issued uh yesterday i i'm i'm not
certain of that but you may be you may
know something that i don't and that's
one of the reasons why
i think it'd be really quite sensible of
us all just to
you know wait until the investigation is
concluded
okay and and just one further point that
i want to put
can you appreciate prime minister that
throwing a party for tory mps on the
anniversary of the covert memorial on
the day that
some fixed penalty notices were issued
for um lockdown breaking in whitehall
might give the impression to the public
that you don't care about how they feel
about this
i think that uh this government has
uh done everything we can to
protect the public throughout the
pandemic and um
and
and yes i i care deeply
uh but we have worked incredibly hard
across the whole of government to look
after the population uh during the
pandemic i'm i'm
some things went well
uh some things went went less well
uh it was an incredibly difficult time
but i think overall the record of the of
the uk government in in dealing with
kovid has been uh pretty remarkable and
um i i am proud of it okay
uh perhaps just lately before i move on
to ukraine uh you say you wait to answer
questions when the investigation is
finished that is that when the met
police say we have now investigated and
finished our investigations yes because
it's only at that stage
uh
um
ms bets that we we will be able to
um uh
conclude the sugray uh process and
and that's when uh we'll be able to wrap
the whole thing up and that i mean
genuinely i think is the sensible moment
uh for us to have a discussion so the
net police finishing is the time okay
that's fine uh moving on to uh ukraine
now uh tom dugan artist chair of the
foreign fest
so good to see you um has uh president
macron been speaking to putin for too
long
i i think it's uh tom i i think it's
very very important that
um
the
unity of the
of the west and the unity of nato uh
should be
uh
remembered and uh and and prioritized
and that's that's what we're we're doing
um
i think
uh
the
question of uh of negotiation with with
vladimir putin of the value of those
of those negotiations is is an open one
um my own view is that
that
putin is plainly not to be
to be trusted i think
the most important thing and here i
think emmanuel and i would be in total
agreement the most important thing is
that whatever happens should be
what the ukrainians want and it's for
for them
to decide uh what their future should be
that is what is at stake here uh it's
not um for any of us
uh
you know whatever we may think to try to
create
a future
for them it's for them to decide that
do you agree with president biden that
the end state should be not only
russians out of ukraine but putin gone
from the kremlin look i understand why
joe biden said that and i understand the
uh you know the
the
frustrations that people feel about
putin and
um
to to desire a change of of government
in in itself is not any an ignoble thing
i think you know there are clinton
people around this this horseshoe uh you
know the perhaps who would like to
change in this government uh but
uh that you know that's the objective of
a lot of democratic politics but
it is literally absolutely clear it's
not the objective of the uk government
and it's very very important we we get
everybody guessed this
we are simply setting out to help
uh to protect the people of ukraine and
to protect them against absolutely
barbaric and unreasonable violence
that's what we're doing and i think that
it's it's vital to to keep that you know
141 votes
tom in the in the in the u.n general
assembly against what russia had done
and that was a fantastic thing there was
as you know there was a more recent vote
which almost kept the number
you've got to keep this simple and so
given the efforts is to protect uh the
ukrainian people i think something that
would all welcome
what did you think of the franco-turkish
greek attempt at humanitarian aid
you mean for mario paul yes
uh i think that um
i i i'm obviously in favor of of
humanitarian aid but to tom you and i
remember this ruthless cynicism with
which putin manipulates so-called
humanitarian aid uh corridors uh in
order to uh to throw his opposition off
off balance uh you remember what he did
in aleppo uh the constant dangling of
peace processes and humanitarian
corridors when really what he wants to
go on and do is administer extreme
violence and uh you know again i i'm
i think it's a good thing to to be
humanitarian it's good
to help people to help refugees uh but
i have my doubts about the the genuine
willingness of putin to cooperate do you
think however there's more that we could
do for civil defense i mean there are
various
avenues that we could assist with uh the
ukrainian government itself has asked
for for example armored land rover's
assistance in
if you like white helmets type units uh
within ukraine is that something that
you're already looking at
well we're certainly looking at going up
a gear now in our support for
uh the ukrainians in as they defend
themselves this is
civilian assistance rather than military
assistance if you like
right in mario paul the issue is as you
know that uh the
uh
ukrainian defenders are now uh pretty
much en encircled and there's a
humanitarian
catastrophe the question is can we help
the
ukrainians relieve mario paul if that
were possible uh would armour would ap
seas be useful for them you mentioned
armored
land rovers uh we are the ambulances uh
well we're certainly looking at that but
i'm afraid it depends very much on the
environment that putin's forces are
willing to allow prime minister i
understand that i'm i'm actually more
looking at the civilian assistance that
could go white helmets
white helmets type arrangement so
armoured ambulance is to help for
example around kiev around
the danipa river
areas where the ukrainians are suffering
not just from casualties from the
artillery but then the aid units that go
in and assist the injured are being uh
targeted by russian units and in those
areas armored ambulances could help um
possibly some extra logistical supplies
in terms of uh body armor and so on for
for medical units is that something i
think it's a very very interesting
suggestion tom i mean it's not something
i'm that vladimir zelinski has
has requested so far uh from from me
personally but that doesn't mean that
the ukrainians haven't uh reached out
and asked for it through other through
other channels he's he's asked for a lot
of different things uh so far but but
not that i'm certainly certainly keen
let me just repeat then a request from
some of the ukrainian mps they have
asked for it so i'll pass that in
through your system to make sure it's
gone in
um
the question really is also when are we
going to lift sanctions because
presumably if there's stick there also
must be carrot at what stage
do you think that sanctions could be
lifted on russia does it have to be
ukraine whole and entire including
crimea does it have to be the liberation
as well of the occupied areas of georgia
what is what is the
line that you all thinking about
i certainly don't think that you could
expect the g7
to lift sanctions
uh simply because there's been a
ceasefire
in uh in ukraine and
um that again
goes straight into putin's playbook
in my view we should continue to
intensify sanctions with a rolling
program
uh until every single one of his troops
is is out of ukraine including crime and
uh
as i said every single one of his troops
is out of ukraine would you include
georgia
that's been occupied now as you know
since 2008
south asset here in abkhazia i i think
that we
need to have a um
a total rethink about all the support
that we offer uh
countries such as
uh
georgia and and
ukraine
um and what
were
evolving towards
is i think
a new way of looking at
ukraine so if
and and other countries or former
countries in the
form former cis a former or former
soviet union
and
i think there's
because of the sheer quantity
of
a nato compatible materiel and and the
the the weapons that we're now supplying
um
we're changing the dynamic and we're
changing the security architecture of
the situation uh bit by bit and there's
going to come a point when i think we
should recognize that this is this has
happened and that uh we are now in a i i
hope that we will be in a position uh
with
willing partners
uh to offer and not not an article five
security guarantee to to ukraine but a
different kind of
future different kind of uh commitment
uh based on the idea of deterrence by
denial
so that ukraine is so fortified so
protected uh with um
uh with weaponry the quills of the
porcupine have become uh so stiffened
uh that
it is
ever after
indigestible
to putin
and uh that is that is the that is the
path that we are now on
and i think and i think that's a very
it's a very productive way of thinking
now about something that has been uh a
problem we haven't been able to solve
which is the the homelessness of ukraine
and other
countries in
in europe's security architecture just
build on that because your point is very
welcome the
the point you're making is very focused
on putin you'd also recognize i'm sure
that putin is not russia he's just
stolen it
the reality is that there is a criminal
conspiracy that calls itself a
government sitting in the kremlin today
centered on a single individual but
there are opposition voices we know for
example of alexa navalny we know about
vladimir karamosa we know of michael
kodakovsky and indeed gary kasparov
there are prominent russian voices who
have
voiced
a possible different future for the
russian people and one that i suspect is
rather more popular to the russian
people than the current system of
vassalage that they live under
would the uk government consider
offering support and assistance to them
and making sure that independent
democratic voices have a way in and
would that include things like making
sure that virtual private networks for
the internet are freely available to
russian citizens who currently find it
very difficult to buy them because of
course the economic sanctions are
effectively assisting uh vladimir
putin's censorship
yeah
we see all sorts of possible futures for
for russia but to get back to the first
point i i i wanted to to make and answer
your first question uh it's it's we
should keep it simple keep this one
simple this is about this is a very very
i've never seen
a clearer case of right and wrong
this is about uh the flagrant violation
of international law uh the invasion of
a totally innocent country and it's it's
about helping helping the ukrainians to
protect themselves now that is something
uh that unites the whole uh the house of
commons uh and i hope and it certainly
unites a large number of countries
around the world and i think we stick to
that
uh
we won't go wrong
uh because i think that the consequences
the logical consequences
politically militarily will you know
speak for themselves and i'm sure you
you have thought it all uh it all
through
um
but when it comes to
supporting
uh
wider civic society in uh in russia uh
supporting uh
free media free internet we do a lot of
that already i think that we're putting
you know we've just put another four uh
4.1 million pounds into supporting uh uh
bbc ukrainian and russian services to
help people uh get at the uh get at the
truth and we're doing a lot more uh to
to promote proper understanding what's
going on prime minister device elwood as
you know is not in the country of the
moment in warsaw and he's asked me to
ask on his behalf
about the integrated review which
rightly spells out looming european
security threats but not the timeline
and he highlights the cuts to the raf's
f-35s typhoon and hercules fleets to the
army's tank and armored fighting vehicle
numbers and the 10 000 reduction in
troop sizes to the lowest number now
since before the napoleonic wars
in this new area of insecurity are you
going to reconsider those numbers and
are you going to request the national
security council to produce an updated
assessment
on the long-term strategic threat
picture with recommendations on how gaps
in our capabilities can be filled
i think if you look at the integrated
review uh it was actually pretty much
spot on in the in the priorities that it
set out for the country and in
particular the the you know it said that
the
euro atlantic area was the number one uh
issue of concern when it comes to the
choice between high-tech uh and uh and
heavy armor um uh
and and tobias and i had this uh
conversation here uh actually i think
that the advantages of high tech in
helping the uh the ukrainians are pretty
manifest now
and i think that the uh the
effectiveness of uh of the end laws of
uh uh of star streak of javelin uh of a
lot of the systems that we're now using
uh switchblade uh these are the these
are the things that are the the uh the
the uavs uh the tb2 uh drones that the
turks have been supplying these are the
game changers and so i think it was
right for us to
go for this massive increase in
expenditure as we did
uh
with the uh the defense review um
10 increase uh but it was also right for
us to focus on on real value uh for uh
for the uk and and make sure we can
maximize our ability to project force
overseas and that's what the the the
integrated review gives thank you
okay moving on now to look at the
humanitarian issues that involved sarah
chapman thank you hello again prime
minister um i'm very grateful that the
uk has committed 400 million to
humanitarian support for ukraine but i
wrote to you on the 9th of march asking
for details on whether or not this money
has actually got to the people that it's
intended for and i haven't had a reply
so could i ask you now some specifics
how much of the uk's pledged financial
contributions have reached organizations
supporting communities in ukraine how
much has reached international agencies
how much has reached local organizations
local ngos mayors and councils right so
sarah i'm look i'm going to have to
right to be i'm so sorry i i will get i
mean look at the numbers high it's we've
given at least 400 million um and pledge
400 million correct i i i i will be very
happy to
uh to share the where it's going we have
as you know lots of um
uh of um
uh
visa application centers in the region
lots of we're doing lots to to help with
uh
the uh the reception of of refugees but
how much has gone to each mayoral team
in in in cheshire and and
exactly how it's being divvied up i will
i will really have to get back to you i
would be really grateful if you could
prime minister um you mentioned earlier
uh humanitarian corridors and how
they're being flamely exploited i mean
they're necessary both to get people out
but also to get aid in so have you
considered doing something has happened
in northeast syria with the un security
council resolutions
to try and keep these passages open for
the safety of everyone
yes i mean i mean that's that's that's
in essence what uh
uh what we're looking at the difficulty
is that um
the the russians are very adept at
manipulating the the humanitarian
corridors um
uh and
negotiations uh
to regroup uh
to deal with other objectives and then
uh come back and and do it again i i
remember uh sitting around many uh
negotiating tables uh talking about
aleppo
and what we were doing to help people
out of aleppo what uh uh what assurances
uh
putin uh could uh could give uh
and it was in the end turned out to be
uh more or less completely valued as
they pulverized uh aleppo and they
didn't stop options that you're
considering
are there other options you're
considering to try and keep those
corridors open
uh well i mentioned one to i mentioned
one to to to tom uh so we're thinking
about uh is there anything we could do
to help actually you know relieve mario
paul which would be um a great thing to
to try to do but you know that that is
going to be very very tough and don't
forget mario paul
is an extraordinary place and you know
it's fallen before
uh to
to russia and then uh being retaken by
by ukraine so
um
what's happening is absolutely tragic
if we if we could think of a of an easy
solution we we do it but we are as as
everybody knows
heavily constrained prime minister i've
also written to you about the mine
clearance that needs to happen and the
british charities that are really
central to achieving that
again if i could get a response to that
um because the the horror that's going
on at the moment
it might only be small things we can do
but if we do all of them hopefully we
can make it a little better you're
totally right sir and you're so right
and uh
i don't know whether you you've you've
heard this where the committee but as
the ukrainians push back russian forces
in some places uh what we are hearing
are absolutely horrifying
tales of what the russians have done and
while they're occupying
you will have heard and been as equally
horrified as i have around the um
countless examples of sexual violence
being used as a weapon of war and this
seems a very systematic
technique if i use that term that the
russians employ
we've got to end the apparent culture of
impunity around this and show that there
are going to be consequences
the uk has been a leading light on psvi
around the world and i'm very proud of
that so what practical steps is the uk
taking to prevent sexual violence and
document those crimes i mean have we got
psvi people there on the ground what
support is being offered to ngos for the
victims and survivors
well we have a psbi uh preventive sexual
violence and uh and conflict uh team uh
working uh with to support survivors uh
hold you know
perpetrators to account uh for what's
happening in ukraine i i believe that
they're in the surrounding area rather
than in country itself um because so
many of the victims are now outside uh
ukraine and i look i sir i agree with
you it's something that uh
the the foreign office pioneered
actually under william hague and um
baroness helic um who i think really
really got that on the international
agenda and and quite and quite rightland
the the tales are appalling but we have
a team in uh in the region uh and we're
we're funding uh them very actively
that's very reassuring and my final
question um i'm sure again you're aware
of the unaccompanied children that are
fleeing ukraine um we've heard a lot of
concerns about a large number of
children from orphanages fleeing into
moldova a country which to be honest is
ill-equipped um with safeguarding of his
own children along the influx from
ukraine unicef reports that more than
500 unaccompanied
children across from ukraine to moldova
in
the few weeks between the 24th of
february and 17th of march
what plans do you have in place to
strengthen and increase the safeguarding
systems in countries surrounding ukraine
and do you have any uh
plans that are uh would enable children
to come to the uk for
safeguarding for example uh as we saw
with the dubs amendment
with with the dubs amendment yes sorry
um
you're writing what you say about
about about children uh it's one of the
horrifying aspects of the of the
conflict that so many women and children
have been coming uh out
what we want to do is wherever possible
to ensure the children are united with
their uh with their families and
uh that's clearly in the best
interests of the of the child um
before
bringing them as you asks
to to to this country
we are
seeing what we can do uh with ngos uh to
uh make sure that they are
um they get all the safeguarding and
help that they need but but it's a
um it is
it's a very difficult problem but
before we go to a dub style solution i
think we need to to think about whether
you know that then the needs of those
kids are probably going to be best met
uh if we can keep them in the area and
get them back to their families i agree
thank you thank you uh moving on to
julian knight
prime minister
our recent committee sessions of russian
disinformation showed that there is a
growing doubts or there are growing
doubts amongst the russian population
concerning putin and his lie machine
prime minister should we not seize this
opportunity we pledge four million as
you mentioned to uh
uh mr dark earlier to the world service
but should we not look to fund a
sustained information strategy in order
to bring the truth to the russian people
about the crimes being committed in
their names
you're so right and you know one of the
uh the depressing things is the uh the
ruthlessness with which uh putin tries
to conceal the reality of what's
happening from the russian population
and genuinely uh you can
you can ring and talk to to russian
friends and they will seriously dispute
uh what what is going on in uh in
ukraine they they really they're afraid
people are very vulnerable to the lies
that putin is uh is telling and we have
to be
extremely energetic in in exposing them
so we've got a government information
cell
uh that's been going for for some time
uh to to counter uh uh
disinformation
you can imagine the sorts of things
julian that it that it that it tries to
to do but what we've what we've been our
whole approach has been to try to be as
as frank with people as we possibly can
about what we know and kind of
demystifying things so it was it was it
was the uk and the us that were out
there in the beginning saying there is a
massive problem there are a hundred
battalion tactical groups on the borders
with with ukraine we know this and we
put it into the public domain similarly
when we uh got information about false
flag operations we immediately put it
out into the into the public domain
trying to uh to just to
fight the
uh the disinformation with them with as
much exposure of the of the reality as
we can
but i think it's starting to have an
effect you know i i think you are seeing
signs now in russia of people waking up
to what's going on that's very much
about their disinformation directors and
since 2013 the russians have been very
very open in fact talking about the fact
that their part of their strategy is
effectively to undermine the west should
we not now turn the tables on them and
all our news media organizations working
together in order to get the truth into
russia by whatever means what we
possibly can and coordinating on
governmental level
yes i mean i think that that's why we're
as i as i said to sarah we're increasing
funding for the bbc um and we're doing
whatever we can to
to to counteract the
the the putin narratives and we are
doing an awful lot to communicate to to
ordinary russians what is really uh
going on
and as i said there are there are some
signs that it's getting through and you
know this new movement with uh green
ribbons and so on i think there is a
growing awareness of the reality of of
what's happening in ukraine but it is
very very far from universal in russia
very far richard today and sputnik have
been blocked but there is nothing
stopping the kremlin starting up a new
media organization via a social media
platform almost in a heartbeat to stop
this happening prime minister do you
think we need the clearest possible
definition of what constitutes a
recognized news publisher in the
upcoming online safety bill
yes and i know you've been you've been
following this uh
uh like a like a like a lynx um the
uh
bloodhound or something uh the um
the
the the
a new a news publisher needs to have a
registered uh uk address uh have a
standards uh code and have editorial uh
control
um
and the the online safety bill will
force will come all such companies to uh
tackle uh illegal the content that is
illegal in the scope of the of the
legislation not all such companies
though because the reality is that
banning russia today and sputnik is a
little important because the real
disinformation is coming from russia is
emanating from platforms such as
telegram as it stands it looks highly
likely that telegram will not be
considered as a high-risk high-reach
social media platform
and in order that telegram amongst
others face the strictest regulation
under the online safety bill should in
the coming weeks the government
outline precisely which specific
companies will be in scope to be
considered higher as news publishers or
as high risk as high risk and do you
think telegram should be included as one
of those high-risk companies look i'm
going to i'm going to have to to to say
that you know i i think that we need to
um
make sure that anybody putting stuff my
general feeling about is anybody putting
stuff
online
um uh it should should in a in a
systematic way putting content online in
a systematic way uh should be defined as
a as a news publisher and it should be
subject to the
uh to the to the controls that we've set
out in the in the bill yeah my final
question promise is partly a request if
you like despite no collective
ministerial agreement and writing to my
committee ruling out such a move just 24
hours before
uh the secretary of state for dcms still
seems intent on introducing a new
committee which will effectively mirror
the work of my committee looking at
online safety this prime minister would
drive a coaching horses
through the select committee system
prime minister will you commit to
investigate this matter write to me on
it and protect the select committee
system which i know you value so much
well i do you know and i value i value
work but i i i'm conscious that the
communities are really a matter of the
house uh but i will i will i will
certainly investigate them and write
back to you thank you thank you chad
okay thanks uh julian we are now to the
issue of visas which is a very uh
challenging one uh thank you
thank you clive and good afternoon prime
minister um i wanted to ask you about
the two uh main routes in terms of
obtaining visas to come to the united
united kingdom
and i wondered on reflection whether you
thought that not going for a emergency
humanitarian visa for those people
fleeing war
was the right decision because the route
that the government had taken
around a family visa scheme which is
about controlling migration and not
about dealing with the humanitarian
crisis as you know has been beset with
over bureau
over bureaucratic
provisions caused confusion and has
changed many times
uh well i
of course i thought about um
having a system where uh
we just opened the doors and no that's
something i said prime minister
emergency humanitarian visa so you would
still carry out the checks you'd be able
to take the biometrics at the at the
border or before someone got onto a
plane that's what you're talking about i
recognize you're concerned about
security okay well thanks um
let me let me just just clarify that i i
i wanted a system i think we're probably
not that far apart then because what i
wanted was a system that was as light
touches as possible and would would
enable people to uh to come here but
would enable us also to do checks
because that you know um
we are outside the schengen uh system uh
we have the advantage of being able to
to clarify uh people's uh uh status
their bona fides and so on um
that's not a bad thing if you want to
have a
um
a a program that really really works and
commands confidence now so far what it's
meant is that we've had 25 000
uh
visas approved um
that that's that's not a bad number so
far they're being handled at a rate of a
thousand a day i mean it's quite a it's
quite it's quite a sizable and the
numbers will mount now uh
quickly there's no cap on these numbers
uh don't forget can i ask you then about
the homes for ukrainians which is the
scheme that still requires a visa it's a
39-page visa or 30-page visa as far as
i'm aware this morning from speaking to
the minister
um but only one in a hundred of the
applications that have been submitted
have actually resulted in a visa being
issued and you were asked at prime
minister's question time today about how
many of those i think it's 2 thousand
seven hundred here have been given visas
how many of those have actually arrived
in the country yes i i'm i'm i know and
i'm afraid i still don't have the uh the
number i know that two thousand seven
hundred have been uh being given uh
visas but um
you know don't forget that this is these
numbers are climbing and
um
the
the the generosity of the british people
is quite remarkable i think almost 200
000 people have said they will take
um ukrainians uh the there's no cap on
the family reunion scheme that's already
right that's already uh the thick end of
twenty five thousand that's you know
that's a time that's a pretty big time i
totally agree the prime minister about
the generosity of the british people but
can i just put to you this case of a
pregnant woman in uh she's in in poland
at the moment she's heavily pregnant
she's been matched under the homes for
ukrainians scheme she's been told that
she actually has to wait to give birth
in poland in temporary accommodation in
order to obtain a birth certificate for
the child for then to be able to get a
visa now is that really what you think
the scheme how the scheme should be
operating if we're so concerned to bring
people over to this country as quickly
as possible well i i can't see any
reason why she she couldn't come here
and have the have the baby here but i'll
be if you if you'll write to me uh with
the details i'll be very happy to look
into it and then can i just ask about
safeguarding um this week
michael gove received a letter from 16
refugee and anti-slavery groups who were
concerned about the homes for ukraine's
scheme risked operating as tinder for
sex traffickers what do you say about
that i think that that is one of the
reasons why it's important to have uh
you know
as light touch as possible but to have
dbs checks
and to make and checks both ways make
sure that we're we have a program that
is really working and
um i think that's important for
for the whole country because everybody
everybody
will want to be as generous as possible
but they'll also want to feel that the
scheme
is really sound and we're getting the
people uh that and really need our help
and that we're helping them in in the
best possible way and do you think the
national crime agency should be policing
facebook groups where people are putting
their personal details and i think
there's one case of a man who said he
was looking for a ukrainian wife there
are children who are posting on those
facebook groups to try and be matched
with someone in the uk do you think the
national crime agency has a role to play
in that i think
certainly and i think that um
the
you know one of the things that i've
become concerned about in the last
couple of weeks is is is what's
happening to
uh refugees uh they're overwhelmingly
women and children uh in in in the
region uh are they who who is uh
predating upon them uh what's happening
to to them uh yeah i think we have to be
very very vigilant about that and that's
why i think the homes for a ukrainian
scheme has got to be something that
where we're we're very very generous we
we open our arms but we also make sure
that
that scheme is not itself uh being
abused
i'm not by the ukrainians but by by by
people who uh maybe you know have have
bad motives i just wondered if you'd had
an opportunity to raise with any of the
social media organizations and facebook
in particular any of the concerns around
this scheme and how how it's operating
by people being able to advertise
and and match through those mediums no i
i haven't personally but i i'm it's a
it's a very good uh point and i'm you
know i'm sure that
uh that uh
that michael gove and his teams are on
it uh but you know
what we what we want we're gonna have a
lot of of ukrainians and that's gonna be
a great thing it's gonna be a great
thing they're fantastic people
and
uh we're going to be we're going to be
very very generous but what we want is a
scheme uh that really does command uh
confidence uh amongst the british public
but also confidence amongst the the
ukrainians
okay
i want to initiate a general issue about
immigration bill again thank you
um
2700 out of 28 300 in the last 15 days
of the visas that have been issued
i happen to agree with everything you've
said about how my constituents the
british people your constituents well
want ukrainians to come to the uk and be
properly looked after
why is it that you think it's moving so
slowly
well it's we're processing about a
thousand a day
and and it is um you know
uh already you've got um
um and what's the population of hereford
bill 140 000. all right okay what's the
population of
well time of hereford
well
the the problem is that in 15 days we've
only done 10 percent of the people
who've applied so we're nowhere near a
thousand a day and my problem is that
what you want is what i want it's what
the people want but it doesn't appear to
be what we're delivering that's my
concern why am i getting what you want
prime minister
we're getting
already
sizable numbers and
i think that that's a good thing
and i think it's you know the
the don't forget most most ukrainians uh
already
um
you know want
to be
in the region they they uh
in an ideal world they'd like to go back
to their homes
um a lot of them increasingly are now
wanting to come to other european
countries they're wanting to come to the
uk and that's quite right
and uh we're opening our doors and
opening our our homes uh the numbers are
going up
quite steeply now i think they'll
continue to rise uh for for a while to
come i think that's going to be going to
be a great thing this country has a very
proud record of of welcoming evacuees i
i'm you know i i don't want to uh sort
of
you know pointlessly to berate official
dumb and uh and you know blame uh of
people for for being slow uh that's too
easy i think we we ask a lot of our of
our officials and our public servants uh
they have to balance some quite
difficult objectives we've just been
hearing some really good questions about
uh about modern slavery about sexual
trafficking about about children uh
about you know gangsters who might be
trading in uh in in evacuees
you you've got to you've got and you've
got to be careful don't forget that uh
the point i made at first of on the
first day in the house is that there
will also be people coming from that war
zone
who may not be entirely who they say
they are and we've had some some cases
sadly of that already
okay take you to the complete other end
of the spectrum
we have on at least three occasions
promised the qataris visa free access
these are very wealthy people who are
unlikely to stay and yet
despite saying we do it three times we
still haven't delivered and i'm really
worried prime minister that everything
you've said to us today i actually want
to happen but it isn't happening and the
only people who are turning up turn up
in rubber boats
why can't we get the right people
through our immigration system instead
of the wrong ones
well um so you
and if i understand you correctly bill
what you're saying is why are we being
so
why can't the can can't the categories
and other gulf countries have visa free
access we want ukrainians we want
catteries okay
in rubber boats no yeah well they're not
getting it no sure so so well the the
nationalities and borders bill uh
coupled with a few other things uh will
help us uh i think uh to do a great deal
to stop the the
cruel trade in uh in people across the
channel uh we will do our best to deal
with that but that's a
that's a a separate issue from
the
um
the visas for for categories and and
others i am keen to have a a more um
uh
fluid uh much more fluid system for uh
for qatar um
and uh we are
um
keeping our uh our
uh
uh system under constant review and i i
recently uh uh
had the
good fortune tell the emir of uh of
qatar um uh that uh we we were likely to
see progress very soon but i don't want
to go i don't want to go beyond that it
seems like when you see this is one of
the things that frankly could could go a
bit faster well that's you were very
very generous in your protection of the
civil service a few moments ago
will you have a very close look at the
people who are not moving at the speed
at which you'd like because you wanted a
light touch system you want that
security you want all the right things
and the country wants those same things
too
um what can you do to make sure that
your wish becomes your command or vice
versa
because we want more of that yeah so
what was what we what you can do uh is
make sure that you increase the number
of uh visa application centers in uh in
country uh
so that you put everything online uh so
so that people can can get their
application cleared digitally and then
and then come here um
and and that's what we're doing and you
have to you have to pay uh to send more
officials out uh to to poland to romania
to slovakia to everywhere that's
currently receiving uh
refugees and and make sure that they're
able to process as many as possible you
have to uh increase the uh our ability
to to help people at leel calais
and and everyone that's what we're doing
excellent so so we can look forward to
the right people arriving in the next
coming days
if you're you are you i i can assure the
committee that uh that we are going to
see uh and
thankfully praise be we're going to see
uh a lot of uh wonderful ukrainians
coming uh and i also think bill uh to
cheer you up even more uh we're gonna
see uh some uh some pretty fluid uh
twoing and throwing uh by our friends in
the uh in the gulf
could we move on uh
to the two schemes um the sponsorship
scheme and the family scheme for
ukrainian refugees
the home affairs select committee was
told two weeks ago that
authorities would get ten thousand five
hundred pounds for each refugee
that came
through the sponsorship scheme and they
would get the same funding for refugees
under the family scheme this morning the
leveling ups committee were told that
wasn't true and there wouldn't be any
funding for local authorities for
refugees that came under the family
scheme even though refugees
coming under that scheme will still need
the same wrap-around support almost
entirely
that refugees under the sponsorship
scheme will get
can we have a look at that because
clearly local councils are under
financial pressures and it just doesn't
seem fair to them to say over to you
it's all yours no help
yes so thanks
thanks clive
you're right about the distinction
and so the
uh the the family
uh the homes for ukrainian scheme uh
attracts a support of uh
uh ten thousand five hundred uh pounds
per person
uh
per year uh for the for the council uh
eight 8 755 pounds per child uh for
education
uh plus of course the 350 pounds uh per
month uh to the
recipient
uh home
um
the
the the broader category the the other
the initial category uh the the family
reunion scheme uh what we're
starting with is access to
benefits
uh access to uh the nhs and all uh
uh mental health care access to
to education uh
free travel
uh and i think
that is a a considerable package of of
support
um the the
way of paying for all that is clearly
through the uh
massive support that we continue to give
to
uh
to
our nhs to our education budgets and and
so on uh they they are going to be an
extra cost but on the other hand don't
forget uh there are 1.25 million job
vacancies
in this country uh one of the problems
our our economy has i'm sure will come
on to it is the need for
more hands to pairs of hands to do
crucial jobs and
i think and one of the things that the
ukrainians will be able to do
immediately is uh is contribute to the
economy by uh by working but the permits
lots lots of organizing though that help
for ukrainians you know finding school
places for the kids uh very trapped in
getting to travel to school and paying
for that giving benefits advice is down
to local authorities who are going to
get not one penny of extra help for
people to the family scheme can you at
least not go away and look at that
because
or you can explain to me what extra
local authorities are required to do
uh under the sponsorship scheme that
they're not going to have to do for
families under the uh of the family
scheme
clive there's a mr best there is there
we are making a distinction because we
uh
we think there's a there are you know
there'll be particular uh types of
people who will uh want to take
advantage of the uh of the of the
homes for ukrainian scheme and and
people who want to come under the under
the family scheme
but i i look i'm not going to pretend
that uh this can be done uh without an
extra call on the on the public purse
but i'm also well i'm also yourself
prime minister will you look at the
funding for cows because they're still
going to have to put resources into
helping people under the family scheme
yes and we've massively increased
support for councils over over the last
year we will continue and we'll continue
to do so
but what i i think that you know
um
[Music]
what we should also recognize is that
uh at the moment um
[Music]
the
uh the dispersal
of
uh of refugees around this country is uh
not particularly equitable
and
uh i'm looking at pete now and it's just
popped into my head there are quite a
quite a few councils in scotland that
don't take
very many uh and
um i'm afraid uh and uh i i think
what would be good to see is uh a
greater spread and a greater uh fairness
in the in the distribution well okay i
don't think you've really asked the
question about funding because i think
we're going to keep on going at this
because councils are still going to have
to provide services for people under the
family scheme can i just come on to that
the fact that two schemes are so
different uh local companies association
told the committee this morning that
and one of the reasons for the
sponsorship scheme is because there
aren't simply the numbers of vacant
affordable housing around the country
which you could just move refuge
refugees into they've already had
councils across the country 144
homelessness applications from ukrainian
refugees now some of them have come
under the family scheme because family
members are not
obliged to provide housing for people
councils would like to house those
families with some of the people who
want to volunteer some of the 200 000
people to volunteer uh to provide
accommodation in their homes but
councils are not being given that
information access to that data really
so so that people have been housing
temporary accommodation rather than the
homes of families that want to receive
them can we at least unblock that logic
well that seems to i i i there's those
bits of
there's i see no reason at all why
councils shouldn't have access to that
uh particular data right i think it's a
very positive move prime minister and
thank you for that um right moving on
then to the other major subject on the
uh the cost of living issues uh neil
parish
thank you mr bets um good afternoon
prime minister um
there's a perfect storm of factors we
are facing the rising food prices the
awful situation in ukraine which is now
known as the bread basket of the world
uh has a knock-on effect on global food
security they produce 12 percent of our
global global wheat exports and a
russian blockade of their black sea
ports is taking that wheat out of the
market this is driving prices up
everywhere
it's also leaving countries across north
africa middle east short of wheat
because much of their supply comes from
ukraine as you know prime minister i'm
always very keen to see us produce more
of our great british food this helps us
to protect ourselves from volatile
markets abroad but also by being less
resilient on imports it means reliant on
imports it means there's a more food
abroad for those countries facing
shortages so i want to see us produce
more in this country growing food is in
the dna of our farmers and producers
they want to produce more and we need to
help them to do it our consumers and
retailers want the right british food
and they want stable prices we are 64
self-decision in all foods but this has
been declining for decades for example
we were 55 percent sufficient in
vegetables and 71
sufficient in potatoes but both of these
self-sufficiency has fallen by 16 in the
last 60 percent 16 16 in the last 20
years so we can boost production the
potential is there the farmers want to
do it the consumers want to buy it so my
question is prime minister farmers want
to produce more food so what can we do
to help them to do it when we have a
strong supply of high quality food so we
can have a strong supply of high quality
food at stable prices
well we need thank you very much neil i
know what a passionate advocate you are
of uk food and farming and you're quite
right and i share your ambition to
that we should grow more of the the food
that we eat and and we can and um uh
we're we're troubling our investment in
uh in the the the farming investment uh
fund uh which will uh help farmers with
their their their equipment and their
and their technology uh but we need to
encourage young people to go into uh
into farming
and to see it as a as a great future it
is a great future when i uh talk to uh
to
to farmers uh one of the sadnesses i
find is they can't persuade their uh
their their kids to to to do it and my
grandfather uh was a was a farmer very
unsuccessfully i may say
and
it's a wonderful a wonderful thing to uh
to do but you need to you need to
support uk
uh agriculture
uh give better business advice to
farmers about uh about the the options
that they that they have i help them
with their equipment help them with
their uh their training uh but also
we've got to we've got to have a bet a
more positive attitude about uh
consuming our own food but also our own
exports and one of the things neil you
and i have just discussed before
is uh the importance of having in every
uh embassy around the world somebody
whose job is uh specifically to champion
uh uk food and farming and that's and
that's what we're doing and it is by the
way growing the whole time the the the
exports are colossal now
of uk food and drink absolutely colossal
i think prime minister what we want to
do is actually get help with costs right
so one of the things is that with
fertilizer as you know um is that the
invasion by russia is combined with
rising gas prices send fertilizers
through the roof the fertilizer now
costs four times more than it did a year
ago at a thousand pounds a ton all of
this is a knock-on effect on the cost of
food the farmers can absorb these costs
around all farming needs fertilizer
livestock dairy cereals vegetables and
even salad production by hydroponics
here in london all need fertilizer but
we only produce 40 of our own we have
two fertilizer plants one is still open
but one is closed if we can contain
fertilizer costs caused by events abroad
we can boost home production and deliver
more stable prices for our consumers and
help with food will world food supply so
the question is prime minister and i
normally would not ask for this but as a
short-term solution can we do everything
possible to reopen that second
fertilizer plant keep them both going
which one where which one is it up in
the up in the north of england right
they're both of them there okay and they
are there
one is mothballed at the moment can we
not get that fertilizer out there
because if we want to produce good food
or more of it we need to do it okay
okay well neil uh look i i i i want to i
want to spread the good stuff over the
fields of this country uh as
passionately as any as anybody and uh
you you've got it you've got to do that
uh and by the way it's one of the one of
the first the cost of uh of of of inputs
uh into uh fertilizer and feed is is is
clearly uh one of the biggest problems
we have but that that is hydrocarbons
and you know uh
feet one of the reasons we'd be crazy uh
to to abandon our hydrocarbons industry
uh is is is because it's it's so vital i
mean
i think 36 of our diesel uh including
all the you know virtually all the fur
comes from russia
36 percent comes from russia
if we're going to end our dependence on
uh on on russian uh diesel for uh for
for
for british tractors and and uh farm
farm vehicles uh we've got it we've got
to think practically about where else
it's coming from yeah
so
uh for sustainable uh hydrocarbons and
uh for basic inputs
now that i'm alerted to the uh to the
need to get the second fertilizer uh
plant going i will i i don't wish to
commit clyde uh to this committee that i
will wave a magic wand and open this
fertilizer part because i doubtlessly
told that there are there are
overwhelming circumstances that make it
impossible but i will i will try to find
out what i can do uh i'll
i look forward to you taking immediate
action
yeah
thank you to uh
to do that
prime minister this is a follows on very
neatly from what you've just been saying
that my interest is in the cost of
living
challenge arising from increasing energy
prices so for the last year or so since
economy started
to emerge from the pandemic
all of our constituents have been seeing
uh astonishing increases in their energy
costs exacerbated clearly by the impact
of russia's invasion of ukraine
to what extent will the energy security
strategy which you're planning
will address the cost of living
pressures
i think you have to
uh provide
as much short-term relief
as you can
to people uh within the fiscal
constraints that we we have the 9.1
billion that were we're giving to help
people with the cost of of energy the uh
abating the the the the council tax uh
and so on uh the
the stuff the extra cash we're giving to
councils by the way uh clive under the
household support fund
uh all those things that we're doing to
help people with with the cost of living
but we've got to recognize that uh in in
the uk we have just failed for a
generation to put in enough long-term
supply and it's been one of those
colossal
mistakes
and
renewables are fantastic offshore wind
i stress offshore wind i think has
massive potential
but so does nuclear and this is the
country that split the atom uh you know
the first the first uh ever civilian
nuclear power station was at calder hall
in cumbria i seem to remember from my
lady bird book uh on on atomic power um
why aren't we doing it why the french
got
56 nuclear reactors and we've got barely
six
what whose fault was it
labor party obviously but uh yeah i
leave that point on one side uh
it was
analytic thank you mel uh uh but we've
got to fix it now
and
uh
i'm gonna pretend that you're gonna get
a nuclear reactor on stream uh in real
time for uh for our constituents in in
in the next couple of years no uh we've
got to do lots of other things including
uh transitional hydrocarbons uh and and
basically helping with the cost of
living wherever wherever we can but long
term
uh and medium term we've got to be
looking at a big ticket uh nuclear
solutions uh
uh seiswell and other projects uh but
we've also got to be looking at small
modular reactors and
bill mentions the categories the
categories are some are just one of the
countries uh that wants to work with us
on on smrs i mean there's a huge list
now of
potential partners for for rolls royce
to do that so your government is the
first government in 30 years to make a
decision on nuclear and i applaud that i
think that's exactly the right thing to
be doing but as you say it's going to
take a decade to bring a major uh system
on on stream well
how long do you think it'll take before
a small modular reactor is contributing
to the grid
uh the um i saw a bit of paper last
night saying that
uh they think that before the end of the
decade um you know uh but they will have
to go quicker than that
so eight years or so so
i'm not going to but you know if we
don't if we don't start now uh this will
be a we won't be fixing the problem but
i you know i'm i'm optimistic that we
can have a you know we we've we've shown
we've shown that we can do things really
fast
the booster rollout was unbelievably
fast you know we've done some things
fast recently i i think we should have a
look at it so there may be supposed to
be a future planning bill to look at the
planning requirements for major
infrastructure projects like nuclear on
exist more moderate relapses on existing
nuclear sites where they're likely to be
welcomed rather than fought
can i just take you back then to what
you were just touching on which is the
transition so as we move uh towards net
zero britain
we have got the we will require
fossil fuels to continue to support the
economy for for another three decades
it's currently
three-quarters of our energy demand in
this country uh is met by fossil
not our fuels demand
if you look at we heat homes we
introduced for transport
um
uh our
oil and gas reserves are currently
depleting rapidly
what is the prospect for the energy
security strategy that you're going to
be unveiling um providing some uh
further exploration opportunities for
the continental uk
shelf
i think that we'll we'll look at all
those uh all those options i i think
um the
hydrocarbon riches of of the world i
mean i'm sorry to say you know
are still vast and uh that is a a bad
thing because we want to move away from
hydrocarbons as fast as we can but it's
also in the short term uh a useful thing
and the there's no doubt the united
states uh disposes of colossal uh wealth
in uh in oil and gas and and so does the
gulf so it is iran uh by the way uh and
you know if we could get uh an agreement
on the on the jcpoa uh not to chuck
another another difficult subject in uh
then then you know that
another source of supply might open up
so does this suggest that you're
uh moving away from the climate change
ambitions that you were um trumpeting at
cop 26 in glasgow in six months ago no
not at all
by the way
i think one of the most
productive lines of uh of research and
one we must not close down the hydrogen
root
hydrogen could be
a fantastic solution particularly for
heavy goods vehicles for farm uh
machinery for for diggers um for ships
uh hydrogen really could be the answer
how do you get hydrogen you get hydrogen
hydrocarbons uh
you so there's a long if if hydrogen uh
is is going to be part of the the mix
and i think it is then hydrocarbons are
going to be part of the of the solution
for the for the long term and that's
that doesn't mean we're if you combine
uh
use of hydrogen with carbon capture and
storage uh then uh you have a a serious
long-term prospect for for the uk
and so i'm suggesting that we make
hydrogen hydrogen is derived from
processing water
and
the oil and gas element of it is to
provide the energy to drive that process
are you suggesting therefore that you're
looking at
a purely a gray hydrogen rather than a
green hydrogen production technique i
think you should look at both side type
both green and and and blue
uh hydrogen and
um
i think you should also i mean if you if
you if you think about people people are
anxious at the moment about the
um
putting in uh
ground source or air source heat pumps
uh to to to heat their homes and
everything everybody's worried about
having to replace their boilers at a
vast expense
well i think you know some for some
people that will be the the right
solution i think the price of those
things will will come down very fast as
as more are made
but
you've also got to look at the
possibility of
going back to where we were actually in
the 60s and 70s when town gas
contained a lot of hydrogen and
you could put a lot more hydrogen into
the uh into into the pipes and is it
that's something that you've persuaded
that just one more question if i may
well i think we're getting close to time
that's okay final question but the next
zero the ambition to to keep going on
the path towards a net zero no that has
not been adulterated or uh or lost at
all so you would welcome our committee
doing an investigation into the
potential for oil and gas exploration
while maintaining the ambition of
networking i think that'd be a very
useful thing yes thank you yes okay
right okay thanks uh
just come back to the
issue of help with people's energy bills
the government's chosen the council tax
rebate 150 pounds
as a major way of doing that
it seemed like a scheme dreamed up in
the treasury passed on to dealer
department to try and sort out and then
passed on to councils to sort out the
further problems when they're coming to
implement it just one particular element
i want to raise with you it's a real
concern
um the for some of the the poorest
tenants in private accommodation who pay
their council tax in with their rent
the 150 pounds gets handed over to their
landlord right and some landlords are in
to get multiples of 150 pounds i assume
that was not the intention of the scheme
and you know is there anything you can
do about it
yeah you mean uh people who who are
paying
um
like
who have paid local local housing they
pay their council tax yeah with their
rent to their landlord yeah the landlord
therefore effectively pays the council
tax on to the council mm-hmm so they
don't get the abandonment they get a
landlord they get 150 pounds no i i will
certainly look into that club i don't i
i don't have an immediate answer but
that that's that's that that's a
a wrinkle that i haven't i haven't seen
it's confirmed being
the second question is if it's too late
to sort it out with the current rebate
if the government goes for an extension
of the scheme in any form i'm not saying
you have to commit to this at this stage
but if you do at some point during the
course of the year would you try and
ensure that the regulations are written
in such a way that the help actually
goes to the tenants who have the heating
costs and not the landlord who picks up
the money i like i i think you'll have
everybody with you on that one client
i'll do my best to ensure that you know
what we want to do is to uh cut the cost
for the for the people who are paying it
and to help people get through uh a
you know unreasonable spike in energy
prices caused by all the things that the
committee has mentioned yeah i think
we're on the same page okay
stephen timms
thank you chad can i just start by
welcoming two recent decisions of the
government one to
make permanent the extension of free
school meals to children and families
with no recalls to public funds and the
other to extend the widen the online
safety bill to
uh tackle scam adverts both subjects
we've talked about before these meetings
right welcome yes welcome those
decisions i wanted to ask you today
first um about a letter
that was sent to you by the chair of the
uk statistics authority sir david
norgrove yes on the 24th of february you
mentioned earlier we haven't got enough
people in in jobs uh at the moment
enough people with lots of vacancies and
his letter to you date of the 24th of
february
said this first couple of sentences
you said at prime minister's questions
yesterday that there are now more people
in employment than before the pandemic
began
according to the latest ons figures it
is wrong to claim that there are now
more people in work than before the
pandemic began the increase in the
number of people who are on payrolls is
more than offset by the reduction in the
number of people who are self-employed
do you accept that correct yes
and i i do and i that's why i took
particular care uh today uh mindful as i
am of of sir david's um uh
um uh chastisement uh on all occasions i
i i
stressed that it was payroll uh
employment that i was talking about but
i mean
there were four hundred thousand more
there are now six hundred thousand more
uh people on uh the payroll than there
were before the pandemic began and that
is not half bad uh when you consider uh
what we were predicting between we we
was everybody was talking about twelve
percent unemployment uh i've seen her
goal yep
point in the letter is that the increase
in the number of people on payroll is
more than offset by the reduction in the
number of people who are self-employed
and you accept that that's correct well
i i think that the
my big my overall picture
i think is right that the um
the employment record of the government
has been absolutely outstanding when you
consider
that people were seriously predicting
that after
covid uh we were going to have uh not
only huge backlogs in in our public in
in healthcare but also unemployment
running at 12 yeah that has that has
been very very far from the case
certainly i completely agree it's
understandable why it is that employment
now is lower than it was before the
pandemic i just wanted to confirm that
you recognize that total employment is
now less than it was before the pandemic
began well unemployment is actually
unemployment employment
i mean if i can the figures from the
latest statistics are that the number of
people in employment most recently is
32.493 million
the quarter immediately before the
pandemic it was
33.073 million so if there isn't there
is now is less than it was there is
again you're making a very important
point i mean
it depends how you look at this
unemployment is
uh is now
back down to which is the thing that
when when uh we were growing up that was
the thing that we were worried about
because that was the terrifying thing
that happened to people they were slung
out of their jobs yeah and uh it was
awful in the 80s and 90s and we remember
that well now that is that is low yeah
that's back down now to pre-pandemic
level that's three point nine percent
what we've what we've got at the moment
employment is still less than it was so
although payroll employment is higher
what you're pointing to uh is a very
interesting thing which is um
the self-employed
uh for reasons that
um
you know everybody's trying to to get a
handle on it looks as though
large numbers of people uh possibly in
their 50s
uh are deciding what with one thing or
another
uh
they want to do something else yeah
and some of them have gone to the
payrolls which is why the payrolls are
higher
some of them perhaps have gone on to the
to the payrolls yeah uh some some of
them some of them are doing um
other things yeah and and so
so
so actually what we want to do
is to find ways of helping those people
back into back into work
and
um
and get them because they have fantastic
skills to contribute on the employment
point you have said in the comments
nine times i think that the number of
people in work is higher now than it was
before the start of the pandemic i think
you've recognized this afternoon that
those statements were incorrect i think
i have repeatedly and i i think i took
steps to
to to correct the record uh earlier have
you oh i hadn't seen it i think i did
yeah i think i think i think i did but i
i've certainly i certainly was very
i've been very punctilious to to talk
about payroll employment uh
miscellaneous but there is there is a
there is a very interesting thing which
is that people in there
there's something happened yeah which is
that people uh in uh
at certain stage in their life are not
are not and not deciding to go back into
the yeah into the labor force now
that so we have we have a we have
vacancies now at 1.25 million
record job vacancies yeah and we and and
frankly those those people have some of
the skills we need and we're probably
short in this economy and one of the one
of the pressures that we have on uh on
supply chains and on inflation is we're
probably short about 500 000 pairs of
hands to do crucial things and many of
those pairs of hands belong to those
people in their 50s who've decided to do
something now
one of our challenges is to get those
people back in the world i completely
agree with that um
moving on
citizen advice has calculated that a
single employ unemployed person was
spending just over 15 percent of their
benefit on energy bills in 2020 it's
going to be 25 in april and it could be
up to 47
when the cap goes up again in october
why was there no help in the spring
statement for people dependent on
out-of-work benefits
look i i
know how tough it is for for people and
to meet the costs of energy and
um i think that
you're
you're raising a again
a very reasonable
uh point and you have to decide where
you're going to put your your fiscal
firepower given that
we don't want to put up
taxes uh and we don't want to borrow any
more so so how are you what are you
going to prioritize and uh who are you
going to you're going to uh
make sure that you uh
target in order to have the maximum
economic benefit for the whole country
uh
what we
think very strongly is it is you're
better off helping people into uh into
work and
uh there are and i
i i know that uh there there are many
difficult cases but that's that's why
uh we're doing the the council tax uh
support the doubling the uh the
household support uh payments that's why
we're doing the uh targeted support uh
for uh for people's energy bills we're
doing all sorts of things to help people
but what we want to do uh if we can is
to is to help people by getting them in
into work and so we just we just talked
a moment ago
those who can't work who are seeing this
massive squeeze at the moment in the
pandemic you increase universal credit
by 20 pounds a week i think most people
recognize that our committee certainly
thought that was absolutely the right
thing to do in a very effective way of
helping people who needed help why
haven't you done something in universal
credit to help people now given this
huge squeeze that they're going to be
suffering over the next few months
universal credit has and we have we've
helped people with
uh change the taper
uh rate in universal credit so certainly
about people who for example can't work
because of health it will help so the
the the
uh majority of uh i think 67 or so 65 of
uh of people who
are on universal credit are either in
work or
can work
and so they they benefited from from
that and i i i
i take your point totally but the way
we're trying to help them
uh is by the uh the direct support that
we're giving for for people facing
particular hardships so uh whether with
with whether you use universal credit
but that's my question because we want
to we want to try to support uh people
as far as we possibly can because we
want to support them through other means
uh we want us we want to support uh
people into work wherever possible and
uh we've just confidence in universal
credit not at all
not at all no stephen i'm sorry maybe
you're really you're asking a really
really important question because it's
sort of fundamental into you know what
we're trying to do we we think that
the way out of poverty is is is to help
people into work
and
all the evidence is that that works so
there are 1.3 million
fewer people in absolute poverty uh than
there were uh you know we're seeing a
decline in the number of kids in uh in
workplace households
getting people and you know we can we
can argue rightly about uh the the you
know payroll or uh or or unemployment or
whatever but the
the overall effect on the economy uh of
having uh
you know
large numbers of people the overwhelming
majority of people in uh
jobs that are uh
paid better
that is that is the way forward and
um
that's why we've got the the way to work
scheme
so that we get uh you know there are 1.8
million people
as you guys say
currently getting benefits
1.25 million jobs vacancies
go figure
we need we nee
we and we've got an economy uh which is
which is massively short of hands well
we need to get those people uh off
benefits and into work and that's by far
the best thing for them so that so
you're asking the right question
but that's that's what our instinct is
okay so we've just got two more
colleagues to to get in before we come
to the conclusion catherine mckinley
and prime minister i just wanted to pick
you up on a couple of things that you
said there
um because
75
of children
living in poverty across the uk are in
working households
and
the figure that you use for um a
reduction in absolute child poverty
not only is that measured against the um
2010
baseline
which shows that that is the number that
have reduced living in poverty since
2010 but it's projected to rise by half
a million next year
based on the government's plans
so
the prime minister will not be able to
say that child poverty has reduced and
by its own measure of absolute poverty
which we believe is inadequate to
measure child poverty in this country it
will be increasing so i wanted to ask
the prime minister about the leveling up
plans yes
do you believe it's possible to level up
the country without reducing the number
of children living in poverty
uh no and we're gonna we're gonna keep
doing everything we can so that so that
as far as i can remember the numbers
currently are and you're you know you're
right there's a there's a there's an
issue we've got to fix and and i'm not
going to pretend it's going to be easy
but we're going to we're going to go at
it as uh as hard as we can but at the
moment at the moment the numbers are um
that there are 200 000 fewer children in
absolute poverty and i think half a
million fewer in in workless households
or i think there's a there's a the
numbers aren't going in the right
direction and
and you're right that at the moment uh
we've got uh the cost of living uh
running uh too high that's why we've got
to do everything we can to abate it to
help people uh through this tough time
and we will using uh the the fiscal
firepower that we have that we built up
because of the way we've been able to
run things but the the the as i was
saying to sarah actually earlier on in
the in the house uh the
the best way forward is to to
get our
economic uh activity going and get more
people
into higher paid jobs that is what we
want and that is that and have that
across the whole country which is why
i'm asking you about leveling up
can you yeah can you tell me prime
minister how many times child poverty is
mentioned or referenced in the
government's leveling up white paper
uh i'm afraid although i've uh i've
never suppose you're going to tell me
it's not me i know the answer to this
i suppose you told me it's not mentioned
at all but none yeah well well that is
not that even if
catherine if that is
so it is it is a a purely formal
accident because uh the whole objective
of leveling up is uh to make sure that
kids growing up everywhere uh have um
opportunity and uh they don't and that's
what leveling up is about
okay
i just have one more question about um a
petition we do need to move on i'm sorry
to come to the end of the time i was
going to ask the prime minister if you
actually read the leveling of one white
papers
have you
i i bet some of it uh i'll be honest
about it that's uh on to the chair of
the treasury segment in australia thank
you good afternoon prime minister good
luck with mel just want to come back to
the discussion you've just had with
stephen timms about universal credit so
if you look at the spring statement and
the actions that the chancellor has
taken prior to that on tax and the taper
around uc there's a lot in that that's
good because it's quite progressive both
in raising the taxes the way he's done
it and the way he's brought them down
as well however the whole the gap is
this area of those who are reliant on
universal credit who are not
in work one of the reasons it's a
particular problem at the moment is that
inflation is increasing very rapidly and
as you will know the uc
uh upgrade to those benefits is pegged
to the rate of inflation back in
september of last year which was three
point one percent
and of course inflation is now projected
to go up to eight nine or ten percent so
those people are going to really
suffer
it will take about 18 months according
to the odr for that effect to pass
through so that the benefit recipients
actually catch up with those
inflationary changes
it would be fiscally neutral
to re-examine and re-index those
benefits say in a couple of months time
and put them up in the light of the way
that inflation is moving so given that
it wouldn't cost any more money to do
that how's that would that not be well
simply because through time as inflation
rises
the uh level of these benefits goes up
and finally catches up with where they
would have been over the longer period
as inflation goes up and then comes down
again but the problem is that over the
next 12 months
some of those that stephen is referring
to will have a net reduction in their
income of about 10 and as he rightly
says they're very dependent on fuel food
and all of those costs
could you ask the treasury to look at
the possibilities i believe they did in
the 1970s when we had energy cost push
problems to look at the possibility of
an interim
up rating of those benefits which will
be at no cost to the exchequer across
the forecast period right i mean i think
i'm gonna have to
go and look at the the how you do it in
a fiscally uh neutral way and look
what we want to do now is to look after
people in the in the in the aftershocks
of the pandemic as much as we as we have
uh during the pandemic and the
aftershocks are proving to be really
quite uh challenging because because of
this this you know the the inflationary
spike in in energy but that's basically
what's driving it
uh as it you know has done before um
i'll i'll look at that but i think the
the direct action that we want to take
is to is to help people in in particular
hardship doubling the uh the household
support fund uh to a billion uh through
councils in in the way that we have um
helping people with uh with council tax
the uh the council tax rebate
notwithstanding the point the excellent
point the clive makes about uh the risk
of that going to the to the landlord i
think we'll have to to make sure we
close that down um you know there are
there are
a lot of things that we're doing
together that are designed
to
tide people over to help them through
a
a tough time
but also taking the steps now
to to build in the long-term security um
but you know i'm
i'm very happy to ask
uh the treasury to look at look at your
suggestion that would be really helpful
prime minister thank you very much
um can i also touch on one comment you
made just a moment ago which was we have
to take a decision as to how to use our
fiscal firepower which is always true
the chancellor has decided in the spring
statement to plant a tax reduction flag
in 2024 that he's going to defend at all
costs which is to reduce income tax by a
penny
the fiscal fire power that we have is
very fragile as the abr has pointed out
it can be wiped out at a moment if
interest rates go above the central
forecast or inflation goes off even
further up than
is anticipated or growth is flatter than
is anticipated if we end up in a
situation where we've run out of fiscal
firepower we've made a commitment to
that tax cut
the gut the chancellor and yourself are
quite rightly saying we're not going to
go out and borrow lots more money that
means we'll have to look at spending so
i just wonder what your assessment was
of the likelihood that you're going to
have to start to look at cutting back on
some expenditure public expenditure and
whether you've had departments start to
prepare for that possibility because it
is a possibility that will end up in
that scenario
i think the
first thing is to recognize the
massively ambitious agenda that the
government has we took a we took a big
decision we had to make a big call uh
when when kobit broke uh and that call
was
um given that we could see we were going
to have to spend so much to look after
people
uh and it you know it was
thick end you know
half a trillion yearbook 408 billion uh
to to to get people through the the
crisis uh all told
um
uh
we knew that that was going to put
massive pressure on public spending
where were we going to go what where are
we going to go back to austerity
what are we going to retrench we're
going to cut we're going to cut our
programs we're going to cut investment
in the long term we're going to cut
fantastic projects that would transform
this country over the long term the
integrated rail plan uh
running out of gigabit massive
investment in in the nhs massive
investment in in education where we're
going to cut all that
to because of the physical problem and
so
i'm just i'm getting to the getting to a
point so we took a decision to keep
going
and that that means as you rightly say
now that the the balance is now
very fine
and
uh the the cost of borrowing
is uh we're borrowing a large amount the
cost of borrowing is 83 billion
uh cost of our servicing our interest uh
is 83 billion
a year and as you say that number can
could easily go up with uh with interest
rates
so
uh we have to be
so so if it came to we have to be very
very careful in the way we handle would
you look better spending or would you
look to and borrow more to protect the
tax cut and that's why we want to keep
going with the
the the plan the the long-term plan that
we have
but making sure that we uh we steer a
steady course and
help people through the
through the short term
but do the
uh make the long-term investments that
are gonna you know what are the what are
the big costs we need to contain uh we
need to contain uh the costs of energy
uh
the the cost of housing uh
these are things that we can start to
address in the uh
by making some big decisions now okay
and finally um you said in response to a
question from neil parish the importance
of exports i think you were particularly
looking at food at that particular
moment um the obr's latest uh
forecast and i think to be precise it's
on page 63 chart i which you're probably
very familiar with
uh shows the um trade intensity as a
percentage of gdp
that our economy commands now in other
words how much exporting and importing
we're doing now compared to the past and
it also shows what happened to all the
countries in the eu and our major
trading uh partners now as brexit and
the pandemic struck almost
simultaneously we all went down so we
all exported and imported much much less
the others as we come out of the
pandemic have gone back up to broadly
speaking where they were before we've
stayed very low
are you concerned that perhaps because
of brexit and the time it's taking now
to strike all these deals with other
countries around the world on the trade
side that we're becoming more of a
closed economy and that of course will
have implications for productivity and
also uh the the living standards that
we're seeking this afternoon to try and
i i'm very keen that we should not i
mean we've done become a closed economy
at all and i think there is a you know
the the attraction we can
we all want to grow more of our own food
and uh and so on but we i'm not i'm not
a believer in in all turkey um we are we
we've got to be healthy
global trading nation and um i i want i
i i do want to see a much more of an
export drive and
uh
i think that you know i think it was uh
liam fox uh of our colleague uh a couple
of years ago uh
i made the point i think i think a lot
of uk companies could sell a lot more
overseas than they do
and now you may have noticed in the
newspapers uh mel there's a big
government campaign now to encourage
them and how long do you think it might
be before we get back to where we were
pre-pandemically i can't i can't i i
can't prophesy
uh that but but
as as i told neil uh we are we are we
are on it we want to champion it and uh
i there there is no there is no natural
impediment uh to our exports uh there is
no uh it is just will and energy and and
ambition and that's what we should be
doing all right prime minister thank you
thank you okay prime minister thank you
very much indeed for answering uh thank
you questions from the committee
well that concludes the hearing of the
liaison committee the prime minister
asking mps questions there let's bring
in our deputy
political editor sam coats who was
listening uh to the answers the prime
minister has been giving for the last 90
minutes or so sam and we knew that uh
this session was going to focus on
ukraine and the cost of living but a
question on partygate was snuck in right
at the beginning
that's right sarah jane these sessions
are useful they're interesting because
they do give you some kind of sense of
the areas
under which the prime minister
is under pressure and i thought across
the 90 minutes it was quite telling
there was a section on partygate at the
beginning pete wishart led that the snp
uh mp and then it went across the uh
other topics ukraine and particularly
the cost of living at the end uh and
actually in that session
you learnt more and had a greater sense
of a promise to coming under fire and
some of the cost of living stuff uh much
more than you did on the partygate stuff
at the start now boris johnson attempted
to retreat uh into an answer to any
question that was thrown at him by uh
pete wishart or labour's uh catherine
mckittle by saying look this isn't
finished yet the police are still
investigating then there's going to be
an intern inquiry by sue grey and then
i'll answer uh whatever questions you've
got in the house of commons and
essentially
whatever the question that was his
answer there was one a sort of glimmer
of light on how he's going to approach
this whole debate uh by saying look at
every stage i've come to the commons i
have apologized and i've tried
trolling told the commons uh what i
believe to be correct that would seem to
be a hint
that he will run the defense that if he
did
mislead the commons at some point and
given the police have judged that laws
were broken during uh 2020 2021 uh
pandemic laws uh it does look like that
was the case because boris johnson said
that didn't happen and all the rules
were followed uh then he would uh run
the defense that that was what he was
told uh and that he was misled and
that's why he in turn misled mps will
that be accepted by mps we will see but
there didn't seem to be there hasn't
been a great hue and cry on that subject
yet but if you looked at the slightly
more difficult questions you heard them
uh pretty much at the end of the session
uh it's always interesting to see what
very senior backbench tories such as mel
stride the chairman of the treasury
select committee uh go in on and he
picked up on two or three issues that i
suspect will be pretty uncomfortable for
the prime minister um first of all he
reflected uh one of the big decisions in
last week's spring statement the fact
that there was nothing to help those uh
people on benefit uh of course benefits
universal credit lagging way behind the
increase in prices way behind inflation
and melstra just saying that prime
minister there's more that you can do to
help doesn't even necessarily need to
cost a lot of money please go and think
about this is it interesting and perhaps
unusual uh criticism critique of what
the government's doing but from a very
senior uh backbencher mel stride also uh
picked up on whether or not brexit is
harming our imports and exports
basically damaging our trade everybody
suffered from the pandemic but only
britain he was arguing according to the
obr
failed to recover after the pandemic was
that because of brexit boris johnson
having to say that actually britain's an
open economy but it's interesting simply
to watch the uh sheer number of
different topics upon which uh tory mps
in particular given that they're judged
during an executioner of a tory prime
minister were niggling away and uh
pushing back at the prime minister but
to be fair it wasn't uh primarily a
session that saw conservatives at all uh
attack him on partygate that is a
process that's ongoing as the prime
minister senses and is arguing and
almost seeking to hide behind it's going
to take some time for the processes
involved the various investigations to
conclude um perhaps putting uh his
moment of uh de numer his moment uh
where it all comes to a head off uh for
some for some time hoping that that
might help his uh predicament but he
really didn't give that much away uh on
that subject in front of the liaison
committee today
uh sam thank you our deputy political
editor that sam coates
today a conservative mp revealed that he
wants to change his gender but has
previously been blackmailed over this
jamie wallace is the mp for bridgend and
he released a statement earlier on today
saying that he has been diagnosed with
gender dysphoria he also revealed that